un mélange de saveurs des pays du monde
de saveurs musicales
la recette alive drive group de natural
trance ont fait partie maintenant d'un
courant parce qu'au début a light rail
c'était un des pionniers de la natural
trance mais après d'autres groupes aussi
se sont joints à ce mouvement et ça crée
aussi un flot de musiciens qui sont
intéressés à la musique moderne à
l'électro au un peu aux tchèques ce que
représente l'électro à réadapter avec le
didgeridoo leurs guitares leurs basses
leurs instruments donc ça c'est
important à nos yeux de représenter ce
mouvement à l'origine de copains greg et
du dos très vite rejoints par quatre
autres artistes est une mosaïque
d'instruments au didgeridoo australien
sitar indien djembé et guitare
électrique
on a de la chance en france on a pu
rencontrer plein de joueurs
d'instruments complètement d'hiver du
monde et donc on a on a appris un petit
peu ces instruments comme le djembé le
n'goni la kora le didgeridoo tout ça
maintenant c'est vrai que dans chaque
pays qu'on va visiter on s'intéresse un
petit peu à leur culture et aux
instruments qu'ils ont et on va essayer
de ramener par exemple en inde on a
ramené le sitar au début ensuite le sida
électrique à lectra n'en finit plus de
voyager plus de 500 concerts à travers
le monde
après voisins le bretonneux ils ont fait
leurs valises direction le japon
[Musique]